good afternoon everybody
welcome to the Yale School of Medicine
and physician associate white coat
ceremony for the class of 2025.
[Applause]
my name is David Brissette and I'm the
interim director of the LPA program
we're fortunate to have with us several
special guests today Dr Nancy J Brown
dean of the Yale School of Medicine
Dr Jessica Lucy Deputy Dean for medical
education
and Pa Jonathan Stewart our guest
speaker for today's event also on our
stage today is Dr Alexander agarino
who's a PA and also associate Dean for
PA education
welcome students staff faculty and the
family and friends of the alumni who are
joining us remotely
thank you for joining us as we celebrate
the class of 2025.
ladies and gentlemen esteemed faculty
honored guests and most importantly the
outstanding class of 2025.
we welcome you to the tradition of the
white coat ceremony
the ceremony in medicine originated in
the 20th century as a symbolic rite of
passage for medical students
designed to Mark a transition from the
classroom
learning to clinical practice these
ceremonies continue the tradition of
presenting a white coat to each student
symbolizing professionalism integrity
and the responsibilities of a clinician
Today We Gather in celebration of your
journey into the noble profession of
Health Care
this momentous occasion marks the
beginning of an amazing Voyage one that
will test your minds nurture your hearts
and ultimately transform you into
compassionate and capable Healers
the ceremony reminds us of the reminds
us of the profound impact that you
as future Physician Associates will have
on the lives of countless individuals
and communities
with this coat you accept the
responsibility of not only medical
knowledge and skill acquisition but also
human connection and empathy with a
patient-centered focus
the LPA program holds a legacy of
excellence in healthcare education and
you the class of 2025 embody the promise
and potential to carry this tradition
forward
each one of you has demonstrated
extraordinary dedication resilience and
academic success to earn your place here
and we're confident that you will
continue to uphold the highest standards
of medical professionalism
your patience and your colleagues will
be counting on you
the challenges of the past few years
have brought into Focus The crucial role
of Health Care Professionals and
safeguarding our communities and healing
those in need both near and far you're
entering a profession that demands both
scientific expertise and unwavering
compassion and we're proud that you have
chosen to embark on this path so
congratulations to you
thank you
so throughout your time here at Yale
will you will gain not only the
knowledge and technical skills necessary
to excel in your future area of practice
but also the understanding that every
patient is a unique individual deserving
of respect dignity and compassion
remember that behind every ailment and
every Triumph lies a human story many of
which may be deeply personal and it's a
privilege to be part of those stories
As you move forward in your medical
Journey seek knowledge with never-ending
enthusiasm embrace the wisdom of your
mentors adopt a process for
self-reflection so that you can be the
best that you can be
don't forget to cherish the camaraderie
of your peers together you will form a
tight-knit community that will support
uplift and Inspire one another
during the ceremony today in addition to
receiving a white coat each student will
be given a stethoscope
beyond the iconic white coat the
stethoscope stands out as an emblematic
component of the attire
intricately linking the student the
identity of a clinician
it serves as a tangible bridge between
patient and practitioner and embodies
the symbolic connection that they share
I'd like to take this moment to share
that every stethoscope to be presented
today was contributed by generous alumni
of the eopa program
do we have any stethoscope donors in the
audience
thank you very much
thank you
what adds an even more profound touch is
that numerous alumni donors have
included a special message for each of
the recipients
thus the stethoscope goes beyond its
role of connecting patient and provider
it becomes a conduit lingering alumni
and current students enriching the
circle of connection within this
outstanding program
so again we thank you for your
generosity
additionally we welcome back our second
year PA students newly minted second
year PA students congratulations to you
[Applause]
so their role will be to robe the first
year students and return they will each
receive a pin from
the first year student the PIN
is the Yale of school of medicine Crest
and as a reminder that is not enough to
master your studies and strive to be the
best clinician you can be the pin is a
reminder that when we get to where we're
going we need to help those who follow
so let this white coat ceremony be a
testament to the beginning of your
incredible Voyage one that's filled with
boundless possibilities and profound
impact
congratulations on reaching this
momentous Milestone and may your time
here be a transformative chapter in your
lives
thank you
[Applause]
now I would like to welcome Dean Nancy
Brown to the podium Dean Brown was
appointed Yale School of medicine's
first woman Dean in February of 2020.
Dean Brown is an alumna of Yale College
and Harvard Medical School she came to
us from Vanderbilt School of Medicine
where she served in many national
leadership roles
Dean Brown is known for her commitment
to education and mentorship and we are
very happy to have her here with us
today
please join me in a warm welcome for
Dean Nancy Brown
[Applause]
good afternoon
as you've heard I'm Nancy Brown I'm dean
of the school of medicine and I am so
excited
to welcome the physician associate class
of 2025.
um
you by the way are entering this school
on the 50th anniversary
of the first graduating class in 1973.
I'd also like to welcome the families
would all family members and Friends
raise your hand
yeah that's fantastic
um
we owe you a thanks for all that you
have done to bring such vibrant talented
and committed
students to Yale
and students you represent 23 States
this is where I get to list don't quiz
me on the capitals but Alabama
California Colorado Connecticut Florida
Georgia Kansas Kentucky Massachusetts
Maryland Maine Michigan Missouri North
Carolina Nevada New York Pennsylvania
Rhode Island South Carolina Tennessee
Texas Virginia and Washington and the
District of Columbia
six of you are first generation
to finish college and three of you are
veterans
a quarter of you identify as groups that
are traditionally underrepresented in
medicine and almost two-thirds are women
three of your class currently hold a
master's degree and an additional three
are candidates for the mph at Yale
the history of the physician associate
and assistant
profession started in 1965 when Eugene
stead who was at Duke
launched the first formal program during
World War II Dr Stead
had
appreciated the need to shorten
education for those in medicine
and running Grady hospital with
residents and medical students he came
to appreciate the value of experiential
learning as an effective way to teach
this program was started shortly
thereafter by Jack Cole who was chair of
our department of surgery and six years
later in 1971 as part of our trauma
program
and as I said the first class graduated
in 1973
so fast forward 50 years and as you
embark on this profession
it's important to take the time to
reflect on the commitment that you are
making
in a moment you're going to Dawn a white
coat
and as you've heard the white coat
ceremony is a fairly recent invention
but in the latter part of the 19th and
the early 20th century the white coat
came to symbolize first the importance
of
science and cleanliness in medicine and
later professionalism and humanitarian
ideals
and it is this commitment that you make
today and every day that you wear this
coat
you will uh
learn much about medicine I hope you
will take the time also to learn about
each other
and to learn about your patients so that
you will see them as individuals
with their own stories
you will have the opportunity and the
tremendous responsibility
to serve at the most vulnerable points
in their lives
Eugene stead the same same person who
founded physician assistant and
associate programs noted that a doctor
or physician associate
makes a mistake if he or she thinks he
or she knows more about a patient than
the patient does himself or herself so
listen to your patients
and never forget that caring for them is
an extraordinary honor
I also want to commend our leaders of
our physician associate program for
their dedication to ensuring that you
have a meaningful enriched learning
experience at Yale
the focus of this program is on critical
thinking and on team-based care
critical thinking because
the diseases that you see today and
understand today are not the same
diseases that you will understand
at the end of your career
and team-based because more and more we
understand that no one individual can
provide good care we have to communicate
and provide connected care
and you will participate in the
interprofessional longitudinal clinical
experience and intermingle with many
different kinds of students while you're
here medical students graduate students
who are making discoveries that will
impact on the care of your patients in
the future
this is a rich environment and I hope
you take advantage of every aspect of it
the next two years will provide you with
continuous opportunities to learn to
grow and soon to be a part of that team
providing care for patients across the
country
there will be exciting challenges ahead
we're very proud that you have chosen
the Yale physician associate program
and we stand prepared to walk with you
on this incredible journey welcome
[Applause]
our speaker today is PA Jonathan Stewart
Jonathan is a native of Connecticut he
received his Bachelor of Science in
biology from Southern Connecticut State
University and an MBA from Quinnipiac
University he's also an alumnus of the
LPA class of 1998.
Jonathan has practiced continuously for
the last 25 years and hospital-based
Medicine including general medicine
oncology Cardiology and medical ICU
he is currently a member of the
hospitalist service at yonderhaven
hospital
since graduation Jonathan has been a
great friend and supporter of the
program he's a dedicated clinician and
has been preceptor for eopa students who
rotate on the hospitalist service
and he's contributed to the education of
many alumni over the years
additionally Jonathan serves as a member
of the Alpa program admissions committee
and also the progress and promotions
committee outside of the hospital in
education Jonathan participates in
emergency medicine response and is a
certified firefighter emergency medical
responder for the town of Madison and
also a company officer for the North
Madison Volunteer Fire Company
in addition to raising two children with
his wife Diane in his free time and when
weather permits I don't think today
would permit
um
Jonathan enjoys running and skiing
I've had the pleasure of joining of
working with and knowing Jonathan for
the last 25 years and I'm delighted to
welcome him to the stage as our guest
speaker so please join me in a warm
welcome for Jonathan
thank you
I don't need these to read
good afternoon everyone
and members of the Yale University
community
I am honored to be here today to witness
and celebrate this very important
Milestone with you all
and in so doing I remember when I was in
the place where you sit stand now
I then perhaps as many of you are now
have feelings of excitement
Pride
and
since you guys are just starting perhaps
a little exhaustion
heat exhaustion exact
ly the time I endured as a physician
associate student was truly some of the
best times of my life
it has been a noteworthy investment with
the return on investment far beyond what
I ever calculated when I first started
that Journey
I have no regrets uh it's been a
wonderful career
still is a wonderful career
and now that we're talking you know I
was asked to prepare remarks for this
um and it was It was kind of odd as I
was going through this it felt like I
was writing my own eulogy
um
so I hope to do it justice
the donning of the white coat has become
a time honored rite of passage
for the newest members of The Physician
associate community
during this ceremony a white coat is
placed on each student's shoulders and
often an oath or pledge of
responsibility and dedication to health
care and the alleviation of suffering to
those afflicted by illness
is recited
the white cult symbolizes
professionalism
caring
and indeed trust which must be earned
from patients
so has each of you Don this white
garment for the first time
and officially take
oh sorry officially take a moment to
reflect on the challenges
and achievement you have successfully
navigated to be where you are today
I ask that you reflect on your journey
which led you to Yale University
reflect on the dreams and the
inspiration that drove you to choose
this course of study
to choose this career path
stay grounded and focused and it will
help you through
um
I ask you to Express gratitude
since we're in Bethel Chapel for me
personally I want to thank God for
granting me work the gifts and the
talents to allow me to be here with you
today the most influential person in my
life was my mother Merlene Stewart
it was through her sacrifices dedication
love all directed towards me that I'm
able to stand here today in this
capacity
at the ceremony I ask each of you to
reflect on the people in your lives that
have kind of given you support and
helped you through your life's journey
family teachers
friends
I ask that you acknowledge challenges
acknowledge the challenges that you've
already succumbed or have passed that
allowed you to be where you are today
and I want to steal you for the
challenges that will come as a physician
associate you will be challenged
um
a good example of that would be covet
when I was in that seat no one
ever for soah
something like that affecting Health
Care on a global scale so soon
so acknowledge the challenges and be
prepared for future challenges
and I also ask that you commit to uphold
the values and principles of physician
associate practice
such as compassion
integrity
excellence
and also the commission
of lifelong learning
um
so it is a small community
um I ask that you know you you be aware
that your actions affects us as a whole
so please
honor The Physician associate in Medical
Practice in general
as you proceed through your learning and
your
training
so as finally as you Don your white
coats today
you will enter a noble and rewarding
profession but also a demanding and
challenging one
you will have to endure long hours
face complex cases
be tasked with difficult decisions
ethical dilemmas
and emotional stress
you will be forced to accept change as
your constant
you will have the privilege and
responsibility of caring for patients at
their most vulnerable moments
to do this well you must not only Master
the science of Medicine
but also the art of Medicine
you must not only learn how to diagnose
and treat diseases
but also how to listen effectively
how to empathize and respect diversity
how to collaborate and Lead teams
how to innovate and improve quality
how to advocate for those who have no
agency
in how to balance and maintain personal
Wellness
the ever elusive work-life balance
and finally you must not only wear the
white coat with pride
but also with humility
I have all faith that you will succeed
I am in the community if you need to
reach out for support or advice or
anything
my name at ynhh.org
or also you can reach out to Dave I'm
always available got lots of good jokes
and lots of good stories it is possible
you will get through
um
that's pretty much it
all right good luck
[Applause]
my name is Jonathan Weber and I am a
proud member of the Yale physician
associate program faculty and I have the
privilege of
announcing names and of first and second
year
students who will
be ready to come up when I call your
names and
Marisol before I do anything
I need to turn to you and ask do I need
to ask them to line up
yeah
thank you why don't you go ahead and
line up as
Marisol has asked you to do
and
we will proceed
coded by Jimmy Robbins
[Applause]
and my apologies I want to thank
Deputy Dean Jessica Lucy for
passing the stethoscopes that have been
donated and we want to thank all of the
alumni who donated these stethoscopes to
our students
[Applause]
Sydney Alexander coded by Joanne hegby
Henry altick coded by Eric Schaefer
foreign
Gabrielle butman coded by Haley Wagner
Diana
Castellanos coded by Michelle Rodriguez
[Applause]
Fernanda
Sakari coded by Nicole romaneschi
Kelly Dunn coded by Elijah Adams
Liam Easton Calabria quoted by Jake
smike
[Applause]
Amelia Eldridge coded by Sarah Hartman
Madeline Cooper coded by Alexandria
Liberty
[Applause]
Eddie kirchen coded by Megan Caroli
Jacqueline Liang quoted by Caroline pay
[Applause]
Danielle Lodge coded by Yoon Hiro
Madeline marks coded by Megan England
[Applause]
Adam Martins quoted by Eric Schaefer
Andrew mininger coded by Matt conorado
foreign
[Applause]
coded by Carly Dominguez
a Lambo quoted by Jessica Nan
[Applause]
Anthony muchiri coded by Joe crook
Fernando duranjo coded by Joshua
Horowitz Benoit
[Applause]
Dalton new coded by Andreas Yanez
Hannah Richelieu coded by Megan Caroli
[Applause]
Davis Rowe coded by Matt conrado
Zachary Scott coded by Austin Liu
[Applause]
Christopher Sweeney coded by Jimmy
Robbins
[Applause]
Cameron Thompson coded by Ashley Manning
Ali Tran coded by Natalie mcbranch
[Applause]
Esther Tsai coded by Adrian no
foreign
[Applause]
Valentino coded by Brianna
bright
[Applause]
Catherine Villegas coded by Maggie
O'Keefe
[Applause]
Jacob Wacker coded by Harrison Young
Hannah Wong coded by Cordelia cluit
[Applause]
Cherie weekly coded by Isabel Batista
Martina Wong quoted by Maisie Cruz
[Applause]
Bree yeski coded by Elizabeth
Encarnacion
[Applause]
I'd like to request one more last round
of applause for our newly white coded
first-year students
hello I'm Courtney fencanel I am also a
proud member of faculty and an alumni of
the Yale physician associate program
um I would like to ask both the class of
2025 and 2024 and any other alumni to
stand so we could read our oath together
just a little little historic facts
um our for our first white coat ceremony
was in 2007 it was the year that I had
completed didactic training and was
entering clinical training and our
fairly newly minted director of clinical
education Zandy Guarino
held the white coat ceremony in Hope 203
classroom so it's been really really
awesome to watch the ceremony grow and
turn into something
every year
and I think it's really great that we
can continue to read this oath together
and maybe someday one of you will be up
here reading this oath
so if we could just say it together
I pledge to perform the following duties
with honesty and dedication
I will hold as my primary responsibility
the health safety welfare and dignity of
all human beings
I will uphold the tenets of patient
autonomy beneficence non-maleficence and
justice
I will recognize and promote the value
of diversity
I will treat equally all persons who
seek my care
I will hold in confidence the
information shared in the course of
practicing medicine
I will assess my personal capabilities
and limitations striving always to
improve my medical practice
I will actively seek to expand my
Knowledge and Skills keeping abreast of
advances in medicine
I will work with other members of the
health care team to provide
compassionate and effective care of
patients
I will use my knowledge and experience
to contribute to an improved community
I will respect my professional
relationship with the physician
I will share and expand knowledge within
the profession these Duties are pledged
with sincerity and upon my honor
thank you you guys can be seated
[Applause]
so in closing and this will be brief
because I know it's warm and everyone's
really looking forward to getting out
with their family and friends I'd like
to thank Dean's Brown Guarino and a Lucy
for coming and participating today I
know they have very busy schedules as
well as all of my great faculty
colleagues and most importantly I'd like
to thank the staff who worked very hard
to pull off this very beautiful Ceremony
this is the first time I think we've had
in Patel chapel and it's really lovely
so thank you guys and
thank you to friends and family to the
class of 2025 who came to celebrate
today or maybe who are joining in
remotely
um you have been and will continue to be
some of the most important support to
these students throughout this training
so we thank you for all that you've done
in the past and all you will do in the
future
to the class of 2025
we'd like to welcome you into this rite
of passage as you begin with what will
be a very difficult rewarding
thank you
and the moment you've been waiting for
this concludes our white coat ceremony
you may process out and take some
pictures and we'll see you at the Elm
City Club next door
or down the street across the street Elm
City Club
for a reception so we look forward to
seeing you there thank you